hi it's Matthew Martin in detail
Charisse Van Noten was all about a
mixture of psychedelic prints and a
strong bold almost military looking
silhouette there was this amazing
shirting detail that had a cutaway bib
that buttoned on itself he paired this
caramel-colored shoe with a darker suit
which I loved the unexpected twist the
pants in the show were either skinny and
super straight or they were a little bit
wider cut with a pleat so you have an
option to choose from he had these
beautiful green velvet trousers they
were slim cut and not as billowy as you
might expect about the trouser to be was
a really cool way to add a different pan
element to your wardrobe I loved all the
outerwear the overcoats were super
tailored and fitted which I thought was
really nice especially when paired with
a really skinny jean and I made a really
cool silhouette there are a lot of
psychedelic prints in the show which are
really interesting some of them are on
the coats a lot of them were on the
jeans and I really liked them on the
jeans especially when paired with a more
subtle cleaner item I thought it was a
really cool way to add a pop of fashion
to the Wardrobe
follow me on twitter at details madam
for more videos from Paris check out
detailed com